[Music]
and no more trolls news not much how
submitted by love from Manchester it's a
Manchester Harvard has withdrawn
admissions offers from a group of
students who posted up see memes like
what kind of meme turned a up on that
social media and social media is
standard now I know Facebook was
invented there it isn't that called
stopping yeah that's what I'm talking
about I think like for us is such a
obscure thought only because like we
were at the cusp of it now so Lola is a
standard of communications our real
names on [ __ ] social media yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy
in fact it oh yeah that's what I thought
that the administrators are all old too
so that's I'm so surprised that they
return to social media to like what I
saw was the progressive old but they're
around young people and they're [ __ ]
smart they're not like our parents
sure and they're having a schema drunk
class oh oh that's right
age ain't nothing well I'm not [ __ ]
the memes kids do so on the official
class of 2021 Facebook page those
students created like a subgroup called
Harvard memes for horny bourgeois teens
so in that space private Facebook group
there were a lot of students that were
posting a lot of memes that they're
saying some of the images not sexual
assault the Holocaust and deaths of
children and kollene also moisturize the
hypothetical haenyeo the Mexican child
as being at that time so that's like
some of this so that way you don't like
genius joke I know looks like a job
where we judge these people let's see
these memes so we can see if it's funny
or not I don't have them
oh sorry this is a class of freshmen
yeah so so once Harvard they got like
the admissions found out about this
group and then they started
investigating further and they decided
to withdraw the acceptance of ten
students based off of these means I
think it's uh interesting and that's
pretty valid because the cool thing
about what hardware does is that they
don't just look at academia you know
they look at the personnel I like at
that Aloha
I actually think that's pretty cool I
mean it sucks for the kids and that's
what happened but at the same time if
they are considered a upper echelon in
terms of like education and society then
they should be able to they should be
able to not select these kids based on
that yeah I agree
I I would say this because I wouldn't
harbor that never look at me ever since
based on GPA personality everything
family lifestyle I wouldn't want to go
there even if I can
why doesn't sound doesn't have a good
sound Harbor but the game of thrones uh
it just sounds like hollow you know we
do it which which Ivy League doesn't
sound weird to you well it's not an Ivy
League but I like pamphlet how'd you
like my sounds son I just like to school
I like to sound too but I didn't like
burn clean very clean but Berklee School
of Music that's dope I like that one oh
thank you yes oh please I go to my grave
no no no you know what's so messed up
you guys remember the term Berkeley
goggles oh yeah yeah it was like it's
like for the students that are within
Berkeley for so long their perception of
what attracted is based on other people
around them so they call it Berkeley
goggles I know I hear that force and you
know you should can Diego UC San Diego
not for not for San Diego State those
San Diego's things yeah my theory is
when the school is more Hardy oriented
or like stupid harder the girls antibody
oh yeah Safford oh my god their
selection is not strong in the physical
realm I will say this I would just this
year I went to a university and the
three girls picked me up and asked them
out like oh so is like you guys have
like boyfriends or anything like that
you guys are dating
you know just regular casual chat she'll
be like no like the boys here just I was
like come on there has to be some tube
guys and I did the show and I looked at
the crowd
understand like I get it it's a slim
pickings here huh yeah it's a little
that's coming from someone like me
so I look at the guys like you guys me
the like pressure hair maybe uh no we
thought your hair or shower cash shower
wash your face stop wearing Skechers
shape-ups you have shape bob Skechers
maybe the acid wash jeans yeah because I
want some Berkeley instrumentum same
thing - she was like - why because like
I I found this out when you know I would
go visit my friends at Berkeley or Davis
what not not Davis Davis and pupils but
like Berkeley I don't like yellow this
girl she's walking hot I like that
that's like pretty average no what do
you mean oh why are all the hot girls
like uneducated and working at coffee
shops in bikinis and stuff but that goes
for the guys too though it goes a bar
not just got the girls it's a guys - or
like that what are the guys doing if
they're not going to college they're
surfing they're sailing boats what are
you talking about why did the girls get
stuck in coffee shops in bikinis and the
guys are sailors what's going on here
what fieger's family what the ball back
out what's wrong with a bikini coffee
shop cuz it just sounds so
unaccomplished opposed to the war you're
degrading women no those girls are
falling $30 an hour Gio how's that
unaccomplished I shut the [ __ ] up
they're very fine actually yeah I do
Jerry Montana I'm not a sauna I will say
this though you would just spit on a lot
of enemies go spaces continue no [ __ ]
you guys because what you guys are
saying is that these girls have nothing
better to do but sell their body
beautiful I serve delicious College
comparison it's now two words
resource management they know what their
resources are and it capitalized on it
BAM look
are you twisting what Joey continue what
you want to say chorus man I'm not mine
we have a high IQ manage that if you got
manage bees yeah and Bravo for them but
I'm nothing in the comparison what do
you have against leave coffee ha ha ha
you guys are just twisting my words
around to be funky before I want to hear
what you want to see yo I'm just saying
so in his comparison he was compared he
was comparing a skill set that this
lifestyle that's like adventurous and
exploitative and and you need to get the
skill to life [ __ ] be on a boat but
then for the females it will just based
on physical people yeah pink coffee
because that's a stereotype
whoo for guys and girls that's also not
sure Dada the girl black the the coffee
shop girls the ones that make the most
unnecessary the hottest or the ones that
know how to play men so that's a skill
set in itself yeah but it would have
been nice if he would have chose to
video game yeah something along with
this even if the girl it should be the
same will ah I see because he's doing
what you're saying is Joe is doing
oranges nothing wrong with nighttime hi
I love not good you do with that and
then you do an exotic dragon yeah
Michael come on bro come on Doh or
discourteous better metaphor do you find
a collection of very hot people for 1000
that's it's the same thing all [ __ ]
what a little whorehouse smells like I
mean uh that's my body I'm just curious
you've got what every event I refuse I
am not that type of man well you're
you're curious about you're gonna be
curious about it yeah but then I feel
like then I'm I did a stigma where
they're not that hot oh they're not I
don't think so I looked on the website
at the bunch you can do that if you go
to Amsterdam jab because there's only
like one legal or like a half illegal
ones here in the United States and it's
in Nevada not Clark County so you can't
get into Las Vegas Ricky goes on atures
baloney a laundry day 34 left - yeah if
you check out their website and the
available entertainers they Law
Institute they look like they should pay
me for sex suicide of them like it's
such an obscure thought that he have in
the past but I got quite happen Chad
this happen to stumble across it I'll
come on you never seen those that
documentaries about the bunnyranch like
did I sure did because I wanted to look
into a live of a call girl all I know is
that certain places smell a certain type
so we are like my hand please it's not
like what I create churches all smell
the same they do right no matter what
Korean church you go to it has this air
of Korean muscle the Korean but I don't
know what kimchi in old furniture yes
that's exactly that is a very good
description hand-me-down furniture
kimchi and some type of stale air makes
me feel better I'm going back on this
whole Harvard by sending their offers me
I don't know what you guys think about
the the social responsibility that
people need to have now when they're
online I think it's very very very good
I think about it I think that is all yet
in trouble but we don't want all the
[ __ ] that we think done well we're
entrepreneurs so it doesn't really
matter for this case it is great because
this is a real source of this is an
actual source where people are actually
held accountable for what they're doing
right so in our world in YouTube you
could say whatever you want you could
say [ __ ] you David I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you I mean really you're not but if you
want to but you know but you know
there's no accountability and use the
people who say that they don't have a
picture on their face but I'm not going
to show the location or anything else
they just want to say what are the [ __ ]
they want you know which I guess like in
there was kind of cool to either say
whatever you want without getting hurt
but in this case no and I like that I
just wish that people like online it was
mandatory for you to have your picture
mm-hmm your name your billing address
address phone number yeah and all that
stuff and their top city most frequented
places yeah I think that would be great
thank all of the internet negativity
trolls yes they be held accountable
it wouldn't like I'm beak as this like
the number one you have see five that
ever lived
everyone that writes their writing I
just feel Mike Tyson and
there's like a there's like 12 year-old
experts that like to tell barn how you
lifting incorrectly in pregnant and that
what I should be doing
it's exciting people like the mix like
the martial art world to like the
opinions are insane it's like if you
haven't done it you can't really speak
too much about it one of the craziest
comments I read recently is someone
wrote on my a video I had I was in the
devasting and they said Barton is not
jealous thing because it's bad for your
back and I'm like that is false
information and I told them did you know
that doctors are now prescribing
deadlifts to older senior citizens to
battle osteoporosis okay and then
outside I try to use that as a chance to
educate people - yeah for your back you
should be like you know it's good for
your back
sticking a dildo up your ass exactly by
tekneqs your [ __ ] spine so you should
take it up your ass mmm
hello JK friends now if you haven't
subscribed to our videos do you know
what to do hit that subscribe button
I'll suck your dick
other than that let's check out the
videos up here
[Music]